Initially, if I compile and run the tester, all
of the methods are actually returning zeros. Let's fix
the amdahl Speedup first. Right now, it's returning 0.
What if I just write it in sort of the
way it is? Now, if I run the tester
again, I'm getting an actual of 2.875. When I
expected 1.6. I think I'd better go back and
fix it. Right now, this is doing the divisions first,
so 1 over s, and s over n.
And then the additions and subtractions in the middle.
And there's no real sense of the fraction
that we started with. This whole piece From s
to n should stay together in the denominator,
and the 1 minus s needs to stay together
in its numerator. Let's try this again. Alright, looks
like Amdalh/s speed up is working, but we still
need to do the cross ratio. I'll try
doing this sort of naively again. I've written this
as it looks but flattened it onto one line.
So, if I return this quantity and I compile
I'm getting an error, unexpected type, required class found
value. This error probably doesn't make a whole lot
of sense to yet but this is a little
hint of what's to come. A pair of parentheses
like this immediately followed by some other quantity has another meaning.
In particular, if you put a type in here instead of
an expression like a minus c. What I need to indicate
is that I want to multiply, and I'll need to do it
over here as well. And now if I try to run
the tester again I'm definitely not getting right answers for the cross
ratio. This is because when we have a bunch of operators
with the same precedents Travel will just start from the left and
move to the right so instead of computing a
minus c times b minus d over in parentheses b
minus c times a minus d. This will do a minus c times b minus d divided by b
minus c and multiply that entire quantity by a
minus d. What I need to do here, is group
the denominator. I could also group the numerator, if
I really wanted to but it wouldn't make much of
a difference. If I compile again, and run the tester, I've
now got two methods working right. Now for the average. I might try retuning
the sum of all of these, all divided by four. Let's
see how this works. If I run the tester, it looks like it works in one case, but
not in the other. Let's look at the second
case. I'm going to go read inside of the tester.
The case that isn't working is when we try
to take the average of 3, 4, 3, and 3.
We should, in fact, expect 3.25, but it looks
like we're losing the decimal. Java is interpreting this as
integer division, because 4 is an integer, and a,
b, c and d are all declared as integers. There
are a few ways I could fix this. I could write 4 as 4., or 4.0 And then it would
get the right answer here. Or I could actually change
all of these ints to doubles, and then I wouldn't actually
need to specify that the 4 was a double. I
can compile this and run the tester, and it still works.
That's because if any of these variables are a double,
this whole expression in parentheses is going to come out as a
double, and a double divided by an int doesn't need
to be done with integer division, that calls for regular division.
This is a really easy thing to mix up. It
looks right to us, but the computer's going to read
it wrong and the compiler won't warn you. When we
ran this with all ints and no doubles we saw that
it ended up being a run time error. This is
a good example of why it's helpful to think about what
you want your answer to be beforehand. Calculate a couple
examples and then write your code. Good book on this quiz.